welcome to this video playing a 15
minute game again against square duel
from the US hmm seems all right now k
never played it before I thought I might
knew the name but at some the statistics
function drew a blank so I haven't
haven't yet played them and opens the
sealian let's see yeah the night off
yeah of course there are many possible
lines against the night off I normally
play Bishop e2 the classical line
championed by cap off and developed by
yefim Geller back in the 50s and 60s of
the last century some the most
strategically focused approach against
the night off probably um there should
be six only yeah i i'm not sure i think
castles are supposed to be the most
precise move as now after f4 he needs to
capture I'm threatening f5 p.m. okay
yeah it's a position a positional threat
not a technical one the point is that
now we have some some difficulties in
keeping the d5 square under under
control hmm I wonder there there are
lines like that but precisely this I
don't think it's too too too great
Bishop g5 I think I need to 545
i might play 9pd sapna i'm not entirely
sure about all this this is really yeah
I think this is not so precise what he
did but my knowledge of this opening is
of course not not excellent mostly based
on knowing some some classical games and
not not due to intensive study yeah what
to do now yeah he has d5 sufficiently
covered at the moment that if I kept you
on f6 my night only three years through
the real problem it is not not
participating in the moment it does not
really control d 5 in any in any way and
if I take on f6 now there is a potential
problem on the dark squares
yeah what other useful moves on an essay
form which is always somewhat useful
preventing b5 king edge loans also move
that might be might be necessary can the
night don't be 3s is really a problem
how to get this back into play it I
don't really see at the moment how to do
that they have a small chatty with my
opponent yourself patty watches the
videos so i just wrote wrote back that
this will be on the channel young a
4chan maybe i'm confusing things and
this is perfectly acceptable for black
there are lines like that was Bishop c4
okay so I gained a game two moro move
basically as he plays age six now and I
really don't mind to take I mean I could
have taken the move before word it felt
like I should have some some other
useful moves first hmm the question is
to how to activate the night night c 1
d3 before this is a very long long route
and there must be a really must be aware
that he can maybe push the five
relatively shortly yeah maybe a four a
five but yes b5 can not not sure
what I'm thinking about is a five and
then a move like rook a form trying to
activate the rook in this way I really
would like him to capture on you two I
don't want to capture myself so that his
screen is activated yeah maybe you do
that now I'm really unsure it is also a
question if he maybe he can maybe maybe
just play D Phi Phi this as possible
like d5 ed5 rope the aid and he gets it
back maybe you can it's not not clear to
me at all he has this Bishop only seven
which looks like a bad piece but this is
not really the case that that Bishop
controls dark squares and covers the
important disick spawn it's a it's not
necessarily bad yeah okay for was what i
was thinking about okay let's let's do
that this might provoke him to take now
d 5 i can probably just capture ed 51
idea behind the d5 pawn sec like 85
Bishop before it now the rukon a4 is
controlling that now okay I don't need
to screw up the picture you with the pre
move it always looks a bit strange this
kind of pre-move image yeah this was
also possible okay if I need to I need
to take him please get the yes let's
check in
yeah yeah well now hit him man Bishop b5
maybe Bishop b5 could be a move if he
does not want to take I mean taking
seems like the normal the normal move I
have an idea if he takes Queen takes
there might be the possibility to play
rook a 5 and 95 this way at the end
controlling d5 with the piece could be
an idea the real issue is the b3 night
if this would be on a good square what
would be a good in good shape but on b3
it's just not good I can also not move
it easily as then we to Hanks and he
will just take it I'm not ok you always
need to look at it at every position
independently but this is very rarely a
good idea to take it as mentioned the b3
light is not a good piece and I get
Bishop c4 to have great control over the
d5 square a6 is also week this is
normally mistake to take the night what
is mentioned every position needs to be
checked for its concrete features maybe
there is something concrete here that
helps black I don't see it at the moment
if you place a roof b8 for example to
attack to take the pawn I just play
Bishop c4 need to go there anyway and he
also does not have any direct activity
with the Queen I mean my dark squares
are a somewhat weak
take Queenie three years just not a move
that that it's writin snuffing if I was
even protected by the rook which was one
idea of the smooth okay so Bishop c4 am
I need to this is part of my my
strategical agenda anyway
yeah night 95mm 95 coming would be very
nice to you know to get a bishop on on
d5 versus the e7 bishop this really
secure something for white good edge and
note that the c-4 Bishop also canvas be
three doses so this is a very very safe
peace hmm yeah black resigns yeah I can
just take it can just take it that's
unfortunate but it was an interesting
game as short as it was but it was
interesting I think this is this is
really a positional mistake after that I
think white is substantially better and
11 main point is that it's also much
much easier to play for white I have a
very clear continuation Bishop c4 and
possibly 95 it's not clear that 95 is
helping me much but something something
like that and now we played this so here
here's some other move I don't I don't
really know what to suggests maybe maybe
something like that and then Queenie to
first to attack a 6 well then it's then
it's it's an open question there are
many possible ideas i can increase
pressure on the ape on the apron is
really can not not that great great the
target now still I can probably win it
it's hard to defend but on the other
hand i also have ideas on the on the
King side and with 95 even even this is
not completely crazy the thing is
wanting the night 95 gets gets really
strong and not quite sure how we should
defend let's say you just just place in
in this kind of fashion then this is in
fact an idea the computer just just
hates the move but i'm not sure i know
it gets it gets to 20 to the area where
white has an etching and yeah man this
is also i don't really know why this
should be bad maybe maybe rookie a one
or so is easier but let's say he keeps
the keep this thing for the moment and
then yeah i can even go here yeah maybe
he has he maybe has d5 some some kind of
defense like that yeah maybe i should
prepare this a bit a bit better and i
grouped you one or something getting
this idea inland and just improve the
rook a bit for the upcoming operations
yeah it's just better for white I mean
what what can you do just the num just
one way to play the other way is to to
simply increase pressure on the iphone
let's say he keep protects that and i
have the additional idea to play b4 b5
maybe besides the fact that it's just
hanging on a sick sent can cannot really
be a cannot really be protected it's
maybe the the point is why i'm not so
sure about taking the bonus at might at
the entity to an exchange of roofs and
this is not really what I want because
in this position we have let's same
place that it's not not so important the
thing is the position for looks is that
the moment close down the sea porn the C
file is blocked by this set up the
defiled by the porn so rooks are not
cannot be used for direct attack but I
have more space and I have those ideas
that might be interesting to use the
rooks effectively I can even consider to
to get this all the way over to to the
King side and
and expand their he has a little counter
play in this structure so on yeah it's a
bit of a sudden end the one thing is
black really shouldn't take what you
should do is either take only two or
play the mentioned move but should be
five which is not bad at all it just
keeps the tension for a moment and hey I
don't really know what to reply maybe
roque five yeah then he has this move to
put some pressure here not not bad at
all I was thinking he would take
actually and then I have these ideas on
a six or maybe rook air-five and 95 I
don't what I never want to do basically
is to to play on 95 let's say he plays a
move like that what I never want to do
is play this move while it leads to the
structure this is not helpful at all
this this can only be an interesting
structure this this type of setup if I
have enough time to get the night over
to e4 but I'm far away from from that
here black is actually am even better
he's got he's got pressure on c2 and the
thing is I can never move the night it's
just a stupid piece because be two eggs
I cannot move the Seaport ever because
b3 hangs so I'm still suffering from the
night this and some moves I must play a
misplaced slowly like rook fif through K
1 and this is may be good for a slight
edge the best seems to be really Bishop
b5 this is a good move it gets also this
at the end to the game with checker
which I overlooked as well I was only
remembering that Bishop b5 a sir is an
idea that's a bit tricky actually what
do i do now i mean i can i can i could
take p.m. and play this move attacking
here Oh
what does he do now
computer some very resourceful as usual
with tactics if I go night here this d5
very embarrassing rook takes oops 94 so
I cannot take them so probably between
muth then maybe look here yeah that's
that's not clear at all he always has
some counter play even even if i take
here for example yeah he has this kind
of ideas b2 is how to how to cover it's
all about the night only 3 which is
stupid yeah does this begs the question
maybe then this is maybe not precise
yeah of course now in retrospect I
should take this is much better I should
take and then maybe consider okay for at
the right moment now we also cannot
easily play fifa this is better i should
do that and now may be here okay i can
do here i think this is at least
somewhat better compared to the game I'm
not thinking that I justice is in great
shape or something good may be here can
tricky tricky business always need to be
a bit cautious with this rook so the
night cannot move fiancée three yeah
let's see this is a typical complicated
middle game for the night off I'm not so
I'm not really sure maybe this I don't
think it's so great but i probably made
some mistake it should be three mmmm but
Bishop g5 looks very logical
young age six a bit of a temple loss but
it didn't oops sorry it didn't really
hurt black so much maybe something else
here I may be taking and then try to
somehow reroute the night they were
tricky okay thanks for watching